a California condor chick has hatched  and left its nest at pinnacles National  Park here in California this is really  exciting if you're an environmentalist  like me this is such a great story the  California condor is an extremely  endangered species this is a major step  towards its recovery yeah very exciting  news thank you Mark our prop master bill  Tull is an avid bird watcher and he's  got the latest on the story bill it's a  little tough  [Applause]  [Laughter]  we have a great show for you tonight  Academy award-winning director of the  new movie Inferno Ron our  [Applause]  legendary hockey player the great one  Wayne Gretzky  no has no life in his eyes that's just  incredible all right miss Oh Jess drama  special gates travis barker is on the  show  coming up we're back Ginny go  [Applause]  you